في عام 2018 ، تم تشغيل أطول سباق أولتراماراثون صحراوي في العالم
عبر
مائتين وسبعين كيلومترًا في خمسة أيام فقط ،
أي 168 ميلًا هذا السباق على صحراء القمر ،
كان الماراثون الفائق
كل يوم مسافة أطول
من الماراثون ، إنه ليس شيئًا
مأخوذ بخفة ،
يبلغ طول ماراثون إلمار مون الترا 19 كيلومترًا عن
أطول سباق صحراوي سابق ، وهو
ماراثون دوس حبلة في المغرب ، وقد
استقطب 214 عداءًا من جميع أنحاء
العالم ، صباح الخير اليوم 70 كيلو في
الصحراء بالأمس كانت المرحلة الأولى فعلنا 50
حالة  غدًا هو اليوم الكبير الذي يبلغ
طول ماراثون قياسي ما يزيد قليلاً عن 42 كيلومترًا أو
26.2 ميلًا
استنادًا إلى أسطورة يديرها جندي يوناني
بين الماراثون وأثينا
للإعلان عن انتصار أثينا على
الفرس في عام 490 قبل الميلاد ، ولكن هناك مخاطر
من دفع الجسد إلى هذه الحدود القصوى  يعد
الماراثون الفائق نشاطًا يعاني من نقص في الرياضة ،
فلا توجد طريقة يمكن لأي جسم
أن يستوعبها من السعرات الحرارية التي يحرقها
بنفس المعدل ، لذا فإن الماء و  يعتبر
محتوى الصوديوم في غاية الأهمية ، حيث
كان هناك رياضي واحد
انهار في اليوم الأول فاقدًا للوعي لأنه
لم يأخذ كمية الماء
التي تحتاجها وكذلك الصوديوم
والإلكتروليتات ، كما يمكن أن تتقلب درجات الحرارة
بشكل كبير من التجمد في
الليل إلى  الحارقة في اليوم هنا ،
نحن في حوالي 25 23 عامًا
، تعد صحراء المأمون
جزءًا من 15 ٪ من مساحة اليابسة في دبي التي تم
تخصيصها للمناطق المحمية
عندما تنظر إلى الأعلى وترى
الكثبان الرملية في الأفق ، إنها ساحرة
إنها جميلة وهذا شيء
عليك أن تجربها لكي
تفهم حقًا كم هو جميل أن
التراماراثون هو جزء من
حملة دبي لتكون العاصمة الرياضية
للشرق الأوسط ، حيث تجلب صناعة الرياضة
1.7 مليار دولار
للإمارة مع أربعمائة حدث
ومليوني متفرج في عام 2017 وحده  هل
أريد أن أكون أي شيء
يسجل الرقم القياسي الأطول والأسرع والأكبر وما إلى ذلك ،
لذلك كان من المنطقي إنشاء مثل
هذا الحدث  هنا حيث يكون الأمر أصعب من
معظم سباقات الماراثون الأخرى في الرمال
وقد فعلناها للتو